my skin is shook mr. Krabs
that's your skin right now my skincare
routine is not a routine at all my
current skin routine is like 30 seconds
I only wash my face like once a day I
don't wash it in the morning I only wash
it which is probably gross no it's fine
right some people recommend that I wash
my face before I go to bed and like it
makes sense that I should but I don't
because it seems like a lot I know that
like Korean cosmetics are like nothing
like I like to imagine it's like
hocus-pocus we even gain the essence of
children and then like taking the years
back my name is sue
I'm from Oh lolli calm Oh lolli sells
curated Korean skincare products a
widely known Kay beauty skincare routine
involves multiple steps up to 10 or
sometimes more the pen step routine it
feels like it could really work and
transform your skin and I think it has
done that for some people which is why
it's so popular ok ready 3 2 1
whoo I like it it's a whole little like
set oh my god there's like several
pieces physics time-consuming
first you want to cleanse your skin in
two steps you would want to use an oil
based cleanser first to get rid of any
makeup sunscreen and daily crime it's
got what happened last night you how
appropriate for you this is me this is
the one you use on Sundays right before
you go to church you're like give me the
holy water it smells like lavender feel
like I want to use this at night like I
want to when you get home from a long
night out on Saturday and you've made
out with like three or four guys and
then you move on to the second cleanser
which is a water based cleanser you just
get rid of whatever's left I really went
in with the massage feels really good
yeah put your face it I really think you
can you grab my little things oh it's
like holding your hand wait mommy okay
okay one go one two three I do feel like
I look younger already
tell me I'm pretty exfoliator to remove
a layer of dead skin cells so that the
products that you'll put afterwards can
do its job much better my thing with
this sheet is that its essence removing
that sales from my face yeah I'd like I
will my exfoliant to like drag what
toners do is it resets your skin's pH
balance and it preps your skin for the
next steps to follow what
I feel like looking at my Steam it looks
like fresh no you need to rub it in you
know just spray essences they usually
come in a really thin liquid it hydrates
and repairs snail secretion filtrated
this is cool these are like like snails
that like live in a spa they probably
better than serums also go and treat
your skin and also hyper target your
very own skin concern if you like gonna
apply you can see that she masks are the
quintessential k-beauty item we say
sheet masks at least once a week I'm
excited about this because this is very
popular on Instagram amongst my female
friends that hashtag self-care like this
this screams I love me this is very like
if you want to go incognito mm-hmm
you'll even go here well she goes here
but she's keeping her flakes moisturize
I meditate when I do this from universe
please bring me abundance and love
please let none of these things prosper
against me that are trying to take me
down I welcome and positive energy and
release negative vibe I cream is a
moisturizer specifically made for your
eye area
I don't know what this is yeah but my
collagen yes it's all about collagen
happy how did you get rid of your baby
what does that do what is it it's like
pushing it in my no problem so
moisturizer goes on to seal and all the
stuff that you put on previously I like
that this College and I could put all
over my face though because I also
notice that the bright
here I have a wrinkle did you ever
notice no yeah wrinkles I don't crack
you sunscreen is not negotiable
it is number one I feel like all of
these things will hydrate and whatnot
but like the Sun blood will protect you
from like cancer you're like Lady Gaga
in our pot I think it'll be a fun new
challenge a fun experiment pause I mean
I said even relax and some unwinding
I've read a book while I do it
I think I look good I thought that was
just meant to do these types of things
while I do this I'm actually going to
meditate I'm freaking out I am
I'm definitely not doing this right this
morning never let it dry I will complete
just a little progress report I have a
pimple right here and I wonder if these
creams and stuff will make it go away by
the end of the week
everywhere else my skin feels so much
softer and that's really nice and my
beard actually has also felt like if
you're like saying usually what I'm
doing to make this work for my time is I
do three of the products before I shower
and then I do like another five of them
after I shower and then I think my face
looks fine you would think that by now I
would know this routine my heart you
know
[Music]
yeah I don't know why but seem like
nasty and these wipes are satisfying
whoo behind my ear okay see once you're
doing this it's not that bad
we're almost done my skin does feel
great and that pimple I had is gone so
I'm gonna meditate really quick and then
um finish out the week strong I think my
week look really good I like doing it it
felt like very like I'm taking care of
my skin that's good I do see the
difference on my skin it feels more soft
and I like that
I just don't really like the time
commitment we think it's actually not
necessary to do all of the ten plus
steps to take good care of your skin you
can really just do it and five and get
on with your life this is nominated I
don't know I think it is definitely like
something that is special self-care you
need an excuse to be late - where do you
like I'm sorry I can't come in what did
you want me to do I'm really not
thinking here called HR I think I
thought I need a meeting I'm triggered I
should go home right now then they'll be
like ah no please do your routine and
then you're a little bit and then you're
good to go
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you